I'm aboard this amazing research and
filming ship called the elucha it's
equipped with two deep diving
submersibles he's one behind me the
Triton and behind that is the deep Rover
a two-man submarine both subs are
thousand-meter rated we probably on
board the ship do the most thousand
meter diving in the world we were
filming from two submersible at a time
and it is amazing edit but it's a
challenge we are just about to enter
their room in the Blue Hole not
basically a cave that forms in a
carbonate platform or limestone when sea
level was lower of rain water was
slightly acidic and it actually
dissolves that limestone forms this cave
you've got a coordinate on the bottom at
depth two submersibles and I'm filming
our scientists and a post right now
we're in the Aleutians mission control
room this is where they communicate with
the subs we spent a lot of time
coordinating shots of the sub passing
overhead and underneath and going along
the ridge the three-man sub with our
past had to come up three times and
change members I wasn't kind of them my
submarine the two-man submarine
we stayed down the whole time so we
stayed down six hours on the bottom and
the six hours went fast but you're also
curled up in a little small space and so
by the end of six hours realize I really
need to stretch my legs
apparently on that day you know we were
the first sets of two subs to go to the
bottom of a blue hole in the Bahamas so
you